Megan Markle you know Megan Markle she
was the Duchess of Sussex princess Megan
sort of she married Prince Harry I've
long had a conspiracy theory that Megan
Markle is a biological weapon
constructed in America to get back at
the British crown for the War of 1812 we
built her here we assembled her
perfectly to just go over to England and
completely destroy the royal family in
the monarchy she's doing a pretty good
job at it well Megan Markle and her
husband Prince Harry they've
come over here to America it's a little
bit like a boomerang unfortunately the
weapon has come back on us and
reportedly Megan margas said she never
wants to set foot in England again which
is a little awkward because her
father-in-law is the king of
England the only reason I care about
this story is not because I I do sort of
like the Royals I'm a little bit
anglophilic but they they can sort out
their own politics the the reason that I
care about this story is what it tells
you about marriage the the state of
modern marriage not just among
Aristocrats and nobility and royalty
overseas but among everyone right here
which
is did she not think of this issue
before she married the prince did did
she not consider whether or not she
wanted to ever step foot in England
before she married uh the second most
notable prince of
England you would think that's the sort
of thing you would consider did she not
recognize that when she married a member
of the royal family a senior member of
the Royal Family
that she might have some duties and
responsibilities that go along with
that and then the moment that she
encountered those responsibilities she
said oh no I want to go play pretend I
don't want to actually be a princess I
just want to go play a princess in
Disney movies I don't want to be the
real thing I just want to play pretend
and then go off to my Malibu mansion
monteo mansion and I don't know Sip shab
and not have any
responsibilities you don't have to agree
on
everything be before you head into into
a marriage with somebody but you do have
to agree on what a marriage is I get
asked for marriage advice all the time
from young
people because marriage is unusual these
days because people are delaying getting
married because our stupid culture tells
people don't get married put your career
first put yourself first don't think
about another person don't have children
for goodness sakes children are a
sexually transmitted disease you need to
use cont reception you need to have
abortions you need to put that off and
freeze your eggs and maybe have a kid
when you're 50 and and this is not
conducive to people's happiness and so
there's a crisis of marriage a crisis of
marriage because the Supreme Court
redefined what marriage is in an absurd
way so we can't even answer that
question but that is that is the
fundamental question of political
Society what are we all doing together
what are we aiming at what do we think
is good what are we pursuing here
together and at what level there's the
national level of government there's the
state level of government there's the
community level of government and then
there's the basic political unit which
is the family which is a marriage and
when you get
married I don't think you need to have
some clinical job interview kind of
procedure I don't think you need to sit
across from your prospective wife and
have a 10 bullet point checklist and say
okay well you you check off seven of the
10 so I guess that's a passing grade you
only get a c but you know okay close
enough maybe we'll get married no you
know that's not the most romantic thing
I ever heard you don't need to agree on
every single thing at least not when you
first get married because by the way
over the course of marriage you will
grow together or you can grow apart but
but if you have a real proper
functioning marriage and you're spending
time together and you're deferring to
one another in their respective Realms
and you throw feminism at the window
then you're going to grow together most
likely that's the question you have to
answer not what are we going to have for
dinner not whose house are we going to
go to for Christmas not even what school
are we going to send the kids to you
have to ask what is marriage that should
be the next daily wi documentary we had
the smash it what is a woman now we need
something just as basic which is what is
marriage and today most people don't
know for Megan Markle marriage
means live out of fantasy from a Disney
movie have a little arm candy Prince to
to accompany your handbag and your high
heels Prince Harry probably had a
different understanding of
marriage the more traditional people
have a different understanding of
marriage than that and it creates a big
big problem if you guys don't agree on
that when you are going in right now go
to pre-born dcom NES finally some good
news because of you our friends over at
preborn have rescued over 44,000 babies
this year alone right now thousands of
mothers are awaiting the birth of their
precious babies and thousands upon
thousands of babies are taking their
first breath since the beginning
pre-born network of clinics has rescued
over 280,000 babies that is a miracle
and for just 28 bucks you can Empower a
mother to choose Life by sponsoring her
ultrasound once she sees the precious
life that she is growing and hears her
baby's heartbeat she is twice as likely
to choose life right now through a match
your gift is doubled your generous gift
will go 100% toward life it is such an
effective way to donate to help save a
life a pre-born fundraises separately
for administrative cost so every dollar
you give is going to go towards saving
babies have your donation doubled today
by dialing pound 250 saying keyword baby
that is pound 250 keyword baby or donate
securely at pre-born
nscw that is preborn
docomo greata wants to crush the Jews uh
here is greata thunberg in
Stockholm uh shaking up her usual
climate activism doing a rain dance and
screaming at the sun monster to uh do
some other kind of dance and scream at
the hebraic people
[Applause]
so I I can't quite make out Swedish
either but apparently the chant there is
cisman which means
uhis yeah which means Crush Zionism this
was at a pro Palestine rally
which leads me back to one of the only
points I've made as this war broke out
because there are high passions about
this war in the Middle East some people
have a strong connection to Israel some
people have family members in Israel for
instance some people spent a lot of time
there some people uh believe in the
theological premises of Zionism this
includes Jews this even includes certain
Evangelical Christians uh some people on
the flip side have strong affinities for
the Palestine Liberation cause mostly on
the left but a little bit on the right
and
I'm I'm not all that interested in those
nuances of the conflict I want to
protect innocent people I want to avoid
World War III but that that's about
where my interest ends in that there are
a lot of conflicts all around the world
I I have an interest in the negoro
carabat conflict between Armenia and
aeran we have an interest in the Ukraine
Russia conflict also because we don't
want to go into World War III but there
lot of different conflicts how does one
make any sense of the Israel Palestine
conflict which has G on for a long time
and it's present form for 100 years and
in some form or other for centuries and
Millennia even and the answer is my
little rule of thumb
is if greata thunberg is on one side of
an issue I'm probably on the other side
just as a rule of thumb okay if grunberg
hates something then that's that's
probably a pretty good recommendation of
it one of the arguments I've heard from
people uh trying to take a more prop
Palestine side here is not the great a
thunbergs not the ilhan Omars not the
Rashida tbes but but sane normal people
is they say well I just don't agree with
the way in which the Israeli state was
established because the Israeli State
the modern Israeli state was
established as a consequence of the
balfor Declaration in 1917 which is a
way for the British Empire to Curry
favor and win some support from Jews
around the world and to support the
political project of Zionism which had
predated it by some decades and then
after World War II because of the
atrocities that happened to the Jews uh
as a result of Nazi Germany then there
was even more political impetus for the
official founding of a state of Israel
in 1948 and received a un Charter and uh
you know but as a result of that it
displaced a lot of people and it created
a new entity on the map and no one had
had any right to do that and that's just
a kind of imperialism and I've heard all
of the arguments I totally agree I
totally agree that it's a complicated
issue sorry I don't agree with all of
the arguments that people make but I
certainly agree it's a complicated
issue but what are you going to do now
even if you think that the establishment
of the modern state of Israel was
questionable it was established what are
you going to do what what on Earth are
you supposed to do what is grun BG's
answer here what is Rashida talib's
answer what is ilhan Omar's answer
seems to me pretty clear the answer is
just wipe the place off the map and then
and then things are not going to work
out very well for the present occupants
but they don't really have any answers
just just like the libs on on other
issues don't really have any answers
they just want to tear things
down they they just want to scream and
yell and even they apply this to America
they say we need to give the Black Hills
of South Dakota back to the Lakota
Sue that's your answer we're going to
give away an area of the United States
that has four US presidents faces carved
into it Mount Rushmore we're going to
give away an area of the United States
has a quarter million Americans living
on it to who to the lakotas Su we've had
the land longer than lot Su have and by
the way the Lakota Su stole the land
from the Cheyenne why don't we give it
to the cheyen why who did the Cheyenne
take it from I I discussed this topic in
a speech a couple nights ago at
vanderville which you can get on the YF
YouTube channel so I I don't just want
to own the libs here I don't just want
to have a nice piy Zinger my question is
what are you supposed to do what's your
answer these people don't have any
answer they just whine and scream and
pretend to be so much more virtuous than
the rest of us that was a great clip huh
now hey you got to ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael YouTube channel
see you next time